oui évidemment c'est une grande joie
pour moi avec toute l'équipe qui
m'entoure d'élus de militants de la
gauche rassemblée d'avoir pu arracher et
emporter cette circonscription qui était
détenu par la droite depuis une
génération plus de 19 ans et avec un
score important puisque nous faisons
plus de 54% nous augmentons le total qui
avait réalisé françois hollande il ya
quelques semaines de plus de six points
c'est la victoire du changement du
renouvellement c'est la victoire aussi
du travail nous avons sillonné avec
nicole clément ma suppléante cette
circonscription de long en large avec
beaucoup de rencontres qui nous ont
poussés qui nous ont donné de l'espoir
et qui nous ont montré qu'il y avait une
possibilité de changement
il fallait tourner la page des divisions
ouvrir une nouvelle page pour le
mâconnais clunysois pour cette terre
magnifique que j'aurai donc l'honneur de
représenter à paris à l'assemblée
nationale thomas thévenoud gérard voisin
nous disait tout à l'heure que cette
victoire votre victoire il s'agit bien
de votre victoire bien sûr mais aussi il
s'agit d'une défaite d'une droite
extrêmement divisé sur mac os oui la
droite était divisée est divisée sur
mâcon et sur le mâconnais
mais moi j'en